hey boss do you want to take a voicemail
or two well actually this is awkward
yeah I noticed something Fula hasn't
left oh usually when the interviews over
flula yeah yeah you know people Ming
hang out no they have things to do
they're they they're big stars oh and
they say you know I've got to go oh no
uh you did this last time too I don't
know if you remember I've no I've done
this podcast before you've done this
podcast before and you didn't leave them
either oh wonderful you have you have
not I mean you must have you must have
something you've got to do right now not
not in this moment in about two to three
hours I will need to uh urinate and then
also have a snack do you schedule
everything in your life yes it's all on
my timers MH yeah so you don't even go
by bladder pressure no I have a Pomodoro
do you know the Pomodoro effect no you
set a timer every 28 minutes and then
when you you do a new thing so oh you
think what do you mean what well in 28
minutes will we be finished at that
moment then I will return to my
automobile and then I will stare at the
sky A4 mentioned call back okay yeah
listen I'm just saying that what you're
doing right now is probably not great
for your career did you get it though
did you get it no I don't even listen to
you anymore I I don't listen to you I
just look at your powerful mandibles and
your Fierce wolf-like eyes uh and uh
listen to your your your voice thank you
um yeah it sounds like a chocolate maker
yelling at me
and what what I'm trying to say is that
it creates a good impression when I say
okay thanks a lot for being here
President Obama and then he has to get
up and go because everyone imagines him
having big things to do you know thank
you so much Jane Fonda and she gets up
and she runs out because she's Jane
Fonda she has a lot to do yes uh you by
sticking around yes are are like a
fungus you're um you're creating this
this illusion and maybe it's not an
illusion that you you really have
nothing to do no it's it's a illusion of
staying power of consistency of always
there can't stop won't stop you know
1960s Celtics you know what I mean wow
okay yes well we were all just thinking
about the 1960 Celtics so shout out to
Drew
Hinson you know you're making my
brothers very happy right now oh nice
yeah hey red hour back huh oh nice are
they Mass holes okay uh let's yes I was
recently taught this word okay yes they
are they okay are my brother oh
nice great um have you been to Boston
yes I've been to Boston I've been to
where where are you from it's just
Boston it's not Boston Boston yeah yeah
it's uh did you like it there I did like
it very much I enjoyed it I like to uh
the Fleet Center was very enjoyable to
see and you are from Boston right
outside Brookline Massachusetts oh I
heard that's the tun of Massachusetts is
that
correct it's not the taunt of
Massachusetts it's a lovely little town
that's right on the Boston line you can
walk into Boston in seconds or if you
get in trouble you can quickly leave
Boston get into chipto out I used to do
that a lot when I'd get in trouble yeah
back in the
day I was quite a naughty boy I like it
what did you do oh I'd stay late at the
library yeah sometimes I take out a book
and I turn it in a day late oh overdue
baby yeah every now and then I'd get a
free sample of an ice cream that I
didn't intend to buy in the first place
sneaky suck a small
spoon so yeah I was a real wild man back
in the day um but uh well it is nice to
have you here thank you uh and and
awkward as well yeah it's cu no guest
has ever been in the third act segment
and you somehow have done it twice both
times you were on right I'm like that
villain that was murdered in act two but
then maybe not murdered hard enough so
then he's back a slasher that gets back
up off the floor yes yes sorry again
yeah so it's funny that we're bringing
this up and you're not even becoming
self-conscious and leaving now you're
still sticking around why don't we try
asking him to leave oh if you just said
this I would leave yes of course flula I
think you should go oh okay great
everyone wait great to meet you byebye
what oh oh I didn't really think that
simple no I didn't either oh wow he
really is leaving wow he's getting his
wait why is he getting separate shirts
yeah why he oh this is a sun wait you've
asked a question yes he's
back he's back so shirts are important
to cover your body because no matter how
many creams you wipe on your face and
arms you can still receive uh sunburns
but you already have a shirt layers
layers are for players man oh okay oh
that's long sleeve long sleeve I see and
a hood oh okay it's a hood yes a hoot is
something else an owl H hood hood hood
hoot hood hood who let the dogs out okay
don't no a hood did not let the dogs out
oh uh okay you um where you going well
okay well now we now you have to stay
because we were going to do something
but we don't have time to do that now
you might as well stick around till the
end oh maybe we could take a voicemail
from you I would love it okay send in a
voicemail hey uh let's let's check
there's a voice mail now I'm told from a
flu la Borg is that right yeah yes
that's correct and he has a question for
us let's let's talk to what's play for
us hey everyone uh it's me flu laor how
are you doing
today okay that doesn't seem like
there's any other sound shy voicemail
that is a terrible voicemail usually
they ask a question let's see if flu
leor left another one hey everyone is my
second message apologies for the first
message which was a question um I wanted
to see how everyone is doing today and
also tonight and I will see for God's
sake he didn't learn from the first
voicemail there's a third hold on oh
there's a third let's check it out hello
Conan it's me flula I just wanted to
confirm our recording of the podcast
tomorrow at 1300 hours and to uh just
confirm the payment which is 13
bisquits do you have those
okay uh I yes we'll give him bis hey
it's me I'm still on the I forgot I have
one more
question Oh you's still on I can't
believe I spoke there was a long Gap in
that voicemail and guess what there's a
gap every time I talk which is weird
just wanted to say everyone um bye-bye
to you and have a very nice day do you
get
it is that the end of it it is and then
what's so weird is that he's still here
no he's still here yeah um I asked you
to do a simple improv what was
it where you leave a you know a
voicemail that was like oh Conan and
tell us what's your favorite pet and it
allows us to fill out the segment but
you couldn't even do that oh sorry no no
it's too late you you you it's
ridiculous okay hello Conan it's me
flula I would like to know what is your
favorite pet so you can fill out the
segment I guess it would be my dog my
dog I love my dog you also have cats so
you you play favorites yeah I like dogs
better I'm a c guy no I hate cats are
tons